Making liquid oxygen is pretty
straightforward if you happen
to have some liquid nitrogen,
which I do.
So what I've got here, my
cylinder of oxygen, and I'm
passing the oxygen through this
copper coil here, which
is immersed in liquid
nitrogen.
The oxygen has a higher
boiling point than the
nitrogen, so it condenses in
the coil, so by the time it
comes out the other end of
the tube, it's a liquid.
So this has been
going a while.
I've nearly got a full tube,
so I'm just going to - Oh!
yep, that's pretty full.
So I'll just put this
down over here.
OK, yeah.
So, good.
A half liter of liquid
oxygen here.
I'll just show you what
it looks like.
So there you go.
That's liquid oxygen.
Probably the first thing you
will notice about it I would
think is that it's actually
blue, which
is a bit of a surprise.
Colour quite often is just a
manifestation of the way that
light interacts with the
electrons in materials.
So straight away, this is saying
that there might be
something a bit funny about
the way the electrons are
arranged in oxygen molecules.
What that is, actually,
is that there
are unpaired electrons.
Electrons usually like to pair
up, but in oxygen, there are a
couple that that doesn't happen
to, and we call them
unpaired electrons.
And there's actually another
unusual property of oxygen
that arises from the unpaired
electrons, which I want to
show you now.
All right, I've got a great big
magnet here, as you can
see, just a couple of nuts
between the poles just to
bring the poles slightly closer
together, and I'm going
to pour the liquid oxygen
between the poles like so, and
there you go.
You can see the oxygen is -
until it boils away - is
sticking briefly between the
poles of the magnet.
So, what's going on here, again,
is because of those
unpaired electrons.
Any electron in an atom or in a
molecule contributes a small
magnetic dipole moment.
Normally when those electrons
are paired up, the magnetic
dipole moments cancel out, but
obviously with oxygen, you
have these unpaired electrons,
that doesn't happen.
So as a result, the whole
molecule has a residual dipole
and acts as a tiny
little magnet.
So I'll keep on pouring this
in, and we can keep
on looking at it.
Now normally when the oxygen is
just sitting in the flask
or in the air, all those tiny
little magnets are pointing in
random directions basically,
so they all cancel out.
So there's no net macroscopic
magnetic field.
But when you introduce the
permanent magnets to the
oxygen here, then you get those
magnetic molecules all
slightly aligning a bit more
than they would normally, and
that creates a net
magnetic field.
So the induced magnetic field
then interacts with the
magnetic field from the dirty
great magnet and you get the
oxygen sticking in the poles.
Now this phenomenon is something
called power
magnetism where you get an
induced attractive magnetic
field in a material.
And I think it was actually
Michael Faraday who discovered
the oxygen was paramagnetic
right here at the Ri.
So one final thing, seeing as
this is liquid oxygen and this
is the Royal Institution,
I'm going to set
something on fire.
This is the classic
demonstration of oxygen
relighting a glowing splint.
Lovely.